bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur social buzz dans la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui je vais vous parler des
mères en tant que sujets politiques
et oui on va bien parler de comment les
maires les parents tu peuvent être à la
pointe de luttes sociales et peuvent
devenir va des figures de résistance
alors dans un premier temps on va voir
un petit peu sociologiquement comment se
fait ce que les mères sont perçus comme
des figures totalement apolitique est
dans l'impossibilité de s'organiser
politiquement
dans une seconde partie g ou présenter
un petit peu un historique des
résistances et des luttes qui auraient
été menées par des mères à travers le
monde et dans une troisième partie je
vais vous présenter un petit peu plus
les enjeux contemporains de
l'organisation politique des mères alors
tout d'abord pourquoi les maires sont
perçus comme apolitique la figure de la
mère cristallise vraiment l'idée de
l'intimité de la famille de l'intérieur
de la sphère privée
par opposition à la sphère publique et
donc à l'action politique va être la
figure de la mère c'est déjà une figure
d'une femme et qui en plus à des enfants
et la charge d'élever ses enfants et
donc historiquement socialement ce sont
des femmes qui sont restreintes dans
l'espace et dans leurs possibilités au
foyer aux limites de la sphère familiale
de la sphère privée et donc du fait
qu'elle soit assimilée à l'intimité au
privé elles sont de fait exclus de la
sphère publique
en fait les femmes qui sont maires sont
assignés à la famille à la sphère privée
parce qu'elles effectuent un travail
reproductif raid le travail reproductive
dans le sens sociologique du terme c'est
ce qui correspond à tous les efforts qui
sont fournis pour éduquer et former la
génération suivante donc historiquement
à socialement dans l'immense majorité de
la population les femmes ont la
responsabilité du travail reproductif et
ce très productif au delà d'assigner les
femmes au foyer à l'intérieur à la
famille à la sphère privée il assigne
aux femmes la tâche en fait de
pacificateur sociale c'est à dire que
dans la plupart des pays
les politiques publiques les politiques
familiales vise à faire des mères une
sorte de personnalités tampon entre
l'état et
la jeune génération pour calmer les
foules et permettent à l'état de
contrôler les masses par exemple on a je
pense qu'on devrait tous entendu dans
notre jeunesse mais voyons qu'est ce que
dirait ta mère si elle te voyais faire
ça et sauf que bien sûr on peut partir
de là remarque un petit peu anodine
presque faussement bienveillante mais
cette remarque elle révèle bien que les
femmes qui sont maires ont ce rôle qui
leur incombe de contrôle et socialement
de gérer en fait la maintenir je dirais
même la paix sociale en encadrant les
jeunes
les maires sont donc presque un relais
de l'autorité de l'état elles sont au
final presque des figures de maintien de
l'ordre donc a priori les maires ne sont
pas vraiment des emblèmes de la lutte
politique et les figures de résistance
n'est et pourtant l'histoire des luttes
sociales nous montrent qu'il en est tout
autrement
en fait les maires sont des figures
extrêmement politique quand elles
décident de s'organiser et d'ailleurs
les luttes sociales les plus longues de
notre époque relève du fait de mer en
effet il ya plusieurs mouvements de mer
qui se sont organisés dans l'histoire
contemporaine et mouvements qui à
l'initiative de tous les autres c'est le
mouvement des mères de la place de mai
en argentine alors ça qu'on appelle les
mères de la place de mai qui ont été
nommés avec mépris les folles de la
place de mai ce sont des femmes qui se
sont organisés pour obtenir la vérité
quant aux disparitions et donc aux
assassinats de leurs enfants pendant la
dictature argentine
donc dans les années 70 alors l'histoire
commence le 30 avril 1977 où quatorze
maires se réunissent devant le palais
présidentiel argentins à buenos aires
est ce pour exiger la vérité sur la
disparition de leurs enfants
c'est une époque où il ya des
répressions extrêmement forte contre les
opposants politiques et donc de nombreux
jeunes à cette époque disparaissent et
sont emmenés dans des camps pour être
torturés et tués
donc ces maires organisent une
manifestation pacifique elles viennent
devant le palais présidentiel
elles brandissent les photos de leurs
enfants disparus et elle demande à avoir
un entretien avec le gouvernement pour
pouvoir exiger en fait la vérité sur
leur sort sauf que les militaires qui
sont devant le palais et bien leur
refuse l'accès et en plus
on leur explique qu'il est interdit de
manifester de manière statique comme ça
devant le palais présidentiel
en réaction à cette interdiction ces
femmes se mettent donc à marcher en
tournant autour de la statue de la place
de mai et sont appelés avec mépris les
folles de la place de mai le mouvement
se structure et donc on va avoir de plus
en plus des symboles donc le fait déjà
qu'elle marche dans le sens inverse des
aiguilles d'une montre pour remonter le
temps jusqu'au moment de la disparition
de leur enfant
il ya aussi les foulards blancs qu'elle
porte sur la tête un bol en fait du
lange qu'on utilise pour les enfants
quand ils sont jeunes et ces images très
symbolique en fait vont vite faire le
tour du monde
il ya une répression extrêmement
violentes contre ce mouvement puisque
deux des mères de la place de mai sont
assassinés en décembre 1977 et femmes en
fait elles luttent contre le silence
contre l'impunité et contre l'oubli
surtout de toute cette période on a
délibérément enlever des opposants
politiques pour les assassiner sur le
même modèle en 1995 se structurent le
mouvement des deux marques nationales
l'aller en turquie
c'est à dire les maires du samedi deux
cas partir du 27 mai 1995 tous les
samedis se retrouve jean laplace
galatasaray à istanbul un groupe de
mères qui exigent la vérité quant aux
disparition de leurs enfants de leurs
proches au moment de la répression qui a
suivi le coup d'état de 1980 dans les
années 80 90 il ya de très nombreuses
assassinats et enlèvements d'opposants
politiques et notamment d'opposants
kurde et ces femmes exige à la fois
qu'on leur rende le corps de leur enfant
est également qu'on fasse cesser
l'impunité en punissant les responsables
de ces crimes
le 25 août 2010 8 à la 700ème réunion
des maires du samedi la répression
policière se fait assez violente et
abouti à l'interdiction de se rassembler
pour les mères de samedi il y a quelques
semaines a été inauguré le procès des
maires du samedi qui se passe en quelque
sorte dans l'indifférence générale
et je pense que c'était assez important
d'en parler dans cette vidéo il y a
également eu un mouvement des mères en
france c'est le mouvement des mères de
la place vendôme qui elle aussi en dd
surnommés les folles de la place vendôme
pour le fait d'avoir tourné en rond sur
le modèle d
argentine le 21 mars 1984 se sont réunis
pour la première fois des mers
essentiellement issus de l'immigration
post coloniale pour alerter et pour
dénoncer les crimes qu'elle appelle des
crimes racistes et/ou sécuritaire contre
donc souvent des jeunes hommes et donc
des enfants issus de l'immigration et se
sont réunis jusqu'en 1986 avant de faire
face à une telle répression qu'elles ont
arrêté leur mouvement
donc vous l'avez vu il ya des luttes qui
sont en fait les plus longues de
l'histoire des luttes sociales
contemporaines qui sont initiées par des
mères qui se mobilisent contre les
crimes effectués contre leurs enfants et
donc maintenant je vous montre un petit
peu quels sont les enjeux de
l'organisation politique des mères pour
ce faire je vais m'appuyer sur un essai
qui a été publié en 2020 qui est la
puissance des maires de la politologue
et militante fatima ou un sac alors un
des points essentiels de l'ouvragé de
fatima moissac
c'est le fait de se mobiliser pour
s'indigner contre la des enfants tease à
sion des enfants issus de minorités
alors ce qu'elle appelle la des enfants
tease à sion c'est à dire de ne pas
considérer comme enfant dans son cas en
france les jeunes qui sont pauvres noirs
arabes issus de l'immigration et cetera
en fait de manière générale des enfants
qui sont issus de groupes subalternes
comme en turquie ça pourrait des jeunes
kurdes ou aux états unis des jeunes
noirs
si le fait de ne pas considérer comme
des enfants ce qu'ils le sont pourtant
est en fait selon elle ces sept des
enfants tease à sion qui mène à ces
crimes
presque systémique contre des enfants et
donc par exemple les crimes contre des
mineurs noire aux etats-unis
s'inscrivent dans cette logique donc
selon elle les maires de s'organiser
pour lutter contre cette désenchante
isation de leurs enfants et doivent
aussi s'organiser pour politiser leur
lutte et pour lutter contre la
déshumanisation des mères en fait ce
qu'elle explique c'est que les mères
dont les enfants ont été tués du fait de
crimes racistes ou de crime d'état et
bien voilà leur ten en de mer qui vient
de perdre son enfant déshumanisé en fait
non acceptés comme une peine légitime
--donc elle explique que il faut
réinvestir cette potion de mer en tant
que celle qui à la fois la puissance de
créer la vie et donc veut protéger la
vie de ce
enfin jusqu'au bout et c'est de là
qu'elle construit son argumentaire pour
montrer la puissance politique que
peuvent avoir les maires cas nous
explique c'est qu'il a besoin d'une
organisation particulière d'organisation
politique faite pour les mères et
notamment dans le cas de la france une
organisation pour les maires issus de
classes populaires en fait selon elle
c'est essentiel de lutter contre
l'inexistence politique de mer en france
il y a des gens qui m'ont fait la
remarque pourquoi une occasion de mer
plutôt qu'une organisation de parents
parce que finalement ça reste à garder
le cliché des merckx que plus de leurs
enfants que les pères et c est ce qu
elle nous explique de par son parcours
en témoignant de son engagement militant
personnel c'est que les syndicats de
parents ne laisse pas forcément la place
à l'expression des revendications
spécifiques des mères de quartiers
populaires tout comme le mouvement
féministe a un peu un angle mort sur la
question des mères et c'est sûrement dû
en fait au fait que la leucémie nice est
structurée autour de la question de
l'avortement de l'accès à la
contraception et caetera et du coup les
maires c'est un peu comme un angle mort
du mouvement féministe actuelle donc l
envie de les maires à s'opposer
radicalement au contrôle social que
l'état attend d'elle et à rompre satie
du revers de la mer tampon qui est du
coup un relais du système de
reproduction sociale
les maires peuvent donc être porteuse de
luttes sociales et politiques tout à
fait intéressante et étant donné que la
sociologie s'intéresse aux mouvements
sociaux
il me paraissait tout à fait intéressant
de vous en faire une vidéo
si cette vidéo vous a pu n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à les singes aime à
partager cette vidéo est un terreau
vivre sociaux logos je vous laisse plein
de ressources pour aller plus loin dans
la voir d'information j'espère donc que
cette vidéo vous a plu et je vous dis à
très vite sur sociaux logos
[Musique]